today is president Trump's 72nd birthday
it's his birthday it's his birthday
true story yeah Trump spent a quiet
evening with loved ones then Milania
stop by and say hello it is his birthday
it is his birthday we must acknowledge
it's the presidential Earth Day I'm told
Trump had some cake aid some ice cream
played some golf then he remembered it
was his birthday
he has his habits he likes to and can it
all again yeah he ate three cakes and
then they told him was interesting
President Trump is now saying Russia
should not be punished should not be
punished for seizing parts of Ukraine
because they speak Russian there no
which explains why today Mexico
announced plans to take back California
Microsoft is working on technology that
removes the need for cashiers and
check-out lines yeah yeah this
cutting-edge technology is known as
shoplifting
the man with the world's largest penis
claims that it ruined his acting career
on the plus side it did get me my own
late-night talk show now the end
[Applause]
that's funny cuz it's not true
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this woman's been laughing way too hard
at that joke stop it right now okay it's
ridiculous
you